[Music]  I feel like on a big screen on an IMAX  screen it would be the most like  immersive experience  it's subversive it's weird it doesn't  take itself too seriously and it's such  a crazy fun wild ride I think it was  inspired very much by Harley and she's  very unpredictable and just like a  little off-kilter I like set broth lady  wanted pan occasion [ __ ] I loved the  sets KK Barrett our production designer  did an incredible job and there's so  much color so much texture and just this  wacky ride who are you guys the DC  franchise has been responsible for  incredible incredible movies that I  think have reintroduced certain  characters in a cinematic way it was  really really exciting to be able to  create a different type of Gotham see  you through the eyes of Harley Clinton  it is such an assault to the sense it's  the the movie and so I think seen it on  an IMAX screen that's how we had hope  people would see it  [Music]  you